a pilot of a small plane declared an
emergency and had to land on a Las Vegas
freeway over the weekend we have the
recording that captures the moments the
pilot knew he was in trouble all the way
to the unusual Landing 95 near Kyle
Canyon Road Brian Wale joins us to walk
us through what happened Brian yeah good
evening Brian and Denise it's something
no one ever wants to hear on a plane
we're declaring an emergency luckily in
this case the pilot was able to land
without any injuries
[Applause]
that's the moment the pilot of this 2003
Diamond da-20 Katana knew he was in
trouble after spending more than an hour
in the air just north of Kyle Canyon
we start making our way towards the uh
the Airfield but we may end up sitting
down on the 95. the plane had taken off
around six Sunday morning from the north
Las Vegas Airport spending most of its
time doing Loops staying at an average
altitude of 7 000 feet until declaring
an emergency an hour later okay if I was
going to pop Alpha North Las Vegas
straight in Runway one to verify
information go back Stay full zombie but
we have two the cause of the engine
problem the aircraft was low on fuel
according to the Nevada Highway Patrol
it caused quite a buzz on social media
uh we've got
[Applause]
in less than three minutes the plane
landed safely with other Pilots watching
133 looks like they uh
uh good landing on the golf course in
the grass uh negative they're on the
highway uh 95 right uh a BMC Golf Course
now that plane was quickly moved off the
highway which reopened a few minutes
later to traffic I did reach out to the
owner of that aircraft and the pilot for
comment and I'm awaiting their response
in The Newsroom Ryan will eight news now